DAN CIRULI: Hi, and welcome
to the Anthos Deep Dive
Session, Part 2.
My name is Dan Ciruli,
and I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
TONY PUJALS: And,
hi, I'm Tony Pujals.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
DAN CIRULI: And we're
going to walk you
through the second part of
the Deep Dive on Anthos.
I'm going to start with a little
bit of a level set to make sure
that you're clear on what
the different components are
within Anthos and
why they exist.
And then I'm going to spend
some time deep diving on Anthos
Service Mesh.
And Tony is going to spend some
time on Cloud Run for Anthos.
But first Anthos itself.
Anthos is an application
modernization platform.
It's a platform that lets you
write applications and run them
anywhere--
on Google Cloud, in
your own premises,
or on other clouds--
even at the edge,
in places like retail
facilities or warehouses.
It's a software-based
solution that
is aimed at solving the
problem of how difficult it
is to run things in
different places right now.
It's there to give
you consistency
across the different
locations you're
going to have to deploy in
order to make your developers
and your operators more
efficient at their jobs.
One of the key things that
Anthos enables you to do
is to modernize in place.
Moving to the cloud can be hard.
Moving from old, monolithic
architectures to new ones
can be hard.
And if you try to do both of
those things at the same time,
well, that's doubly hard.
With Anthos you can modernize
your application where you
are-- still in your data center,
if that's where you are--
and move to the cloud
later as a second step.
It's a much easier
process to follow.
When you do start
running applications
in multiple locations,
Anthos gives you consistency.
It lets you do things like
write policy about security
and have that
policy be in effect
regardless of where the
application is running.
This gives your developers, your
operators, your security people
all consistency to run the
application the same way
no matter where it's running.
One key factor for
Anthos is that it is
a 100% software-based solution.
You don't need to invest
in new hardware for Anthos.
It runs on your
existing hardware.
And at its core, it's based on
a trio of open source projects.
We do container management
using Anthos GKE, which
is, of course, based on the
popular Kubernetes container
deployment system.
The service mesh component
is Anthos Service Mesh,
which is based on Istio, the
popular open source service
mesh.
And up at the top giving your
developers a great development
experience is Cloud
Run for Anthos.
We also have a great
marketplace for the other things
that you might want to run--
other software, databases,
et cetera.
And around this
whole thing, we've
got a very good
policy management
system that lets
you manage policy
across all the different
locations and good operations
tools, so that the people
who are running the software
have the same
experience regardless
of where it's running--
on Google Cloud, in your own
premises, on other clouds,
or at the edge.
Now let me talk a little bit
about my favorite component
in Anthos, Anthos Service Mesh.
And to talk about
Anthos Service Mesh,
I want to talk about a trend
in our industry of moving away
from monolithic applications.
Why did we decide to
move away from monoliths?
Well, actually that second
bullet, to me, is the big one.
Monoliths make it
slow to innovate.
When you have 100 developers
working on an application,
you're probably deploying
that application maybe
once a quarter, maybe
once every six months.
It's very difficult
to test and release
when you're deploying
huge applications.
They're also very
expensive to scale
because monoliths tend
to run on specialized,
very expensive hardware.
And buying multiple instances
of that can be very expensive.
An operation is typically
a very difficult process.
The move to microservices
really addresses
a lot of these
problems, and again,
starting with innovation.
With microservices,
you have small teams
of developers who are each
deploying small units of code.
Because they can
deploy independently,
they can ship a lot faster.
They can ship features
much, much more frequently.
That means you end
up shipping features
to your customers
a lot more often.
And you can scale them
all independently.
Microservices are typically
deployed in containers.
They're running on
commodity hardware.
And they scale independently.
And finally, you've got a
great ecosystem of tools
around operations that
make operating these easy.
So what is a service mesh?
Well, a service
mesh helps you solve
some of those issues
you'll have as you
decompose your application.
A service mesh
transparently, and in
a language-independent way, adds
functionality into your network
calls so that your
developers don't
have to write a bunch of new
infrastructure to handle those.
It's a core component of Anthos,
we offer Anthos Service Mesh.
As I said before, this
is based on Istio,
the most popular service mesh
application in open source
today.
And what does it
do specifically?
Well, there's three
main things that you
get from a service mesh.
First, it gives you the ability
to understand the traffic
between your services.
Now that your monolith is
broken up into microservices,
you've got a lot of components
communicating with each other.
And a service mesh can make
sure that you are monitoring,
logging, and tracing
all of that traffic
so you can understand
your application.
Second, a service mesh
gives you advance networking
functionality to make it so you
can have operational agility,
make it so you can safely
roll out new components,
do locality-base load
balancing if you're
running in multiple clusters.
And finally, a service mesh lets
you secure all of that traffic
and ensure that everything
is encrypted in transit
and you can write policy
to dictate who is allowed
to communicate with whom.
Today, I'm going to focus on two
key areas here in understanding
your application and
the ability to use
some of these advanced
networking capabilities.
And to do that, we're going
to use some chaos engineering
and inject a little chaos
into our application.
Chaos engineering lets
you test the resiliency
of your application by
seeing what happens when
different components break.
Anthos Service
Mesh, in addition to
a lot of other things it can do,
can allow you to inject chaos.
And what I'm going
to demonstrate now
is how we can inject
some chaos to see
how our application behaves
if one of the components
starts running more slowly
or if one of the components
starts failing.
For this demonstration,
I'll be using
an e-commerce application.
It was developed
using microservices
so we can deploy frequently
and independently.
As
You can see, it's a
nice modern application
with a bunch of
services underneath.
Let's look and see what
Anthos Service Mesh can
do to help us understand
this application
and how failures might
contribute to it.
A service mesh is gathering
all kinds of information
about our application, not
just the telemetry that's
being gathered but the actual
topology of the application--
which services are communicating
with which other services.
I can see every service
in my application
as well as how they relate
to every others, including
how much traffic they're
sending to others.
This is some
powerful information.
And for any of these
services, I can dive in,
and I can understand
them even more deeply.
Here I'm getting
tons of information
about my front-end application.
This is the one that
users actually hit,
so it's the one I care
the most about it.
As with every other service
that's deployed in the mesh,
I get great telemetry on it.
I can see how much
traffic this is serving.
I can see things like
what its error rates are
and how they change
over time, as well
as what its latency are.
I can do this on any
one of many time spans.
I can zoom out a little
bit and see how it's
been performing during the day.
One of the great features
about Anthos Service Mesh
is the ability to set
service-level objectives.
As I said, this is
really important,
especially on the
front end for me
to assess the health
of my application.
I can see that this application
is currently healthy.
And I've got an
objective here that says
a certain percentage--
95% of my requests
should be fulfilled
within 200 milliseconds.
However, earlier
today, you can see
where I injected a little
chaos in the system.
And I'm going to show
you how I did that.
I use Anthos Service Mesh
and its use of the Istio APIs
to inject a delay in my service.
I've got a recommendation
service in here.
It recommends new
products to my customers.
And I said 10% of
the time, I want
to add one-second delay to
see what the effect of that
would be on the system.
The system seems to
behave pretty well,
but let's look closely again at
that service-level objective.
I can see that I started failing
that objective some of the time
when I injected that chaos.
And if I look at my error
budget over this time frame,
I can actually see it's going
down relatively rapidly.
Now the system isn't
telling me that I'm
going to run out today.
In fact, it thinks I'm going
to make it through the day.
But this does tell me, as the
person running this service,
I've got a dependency
that I'm really--
that is very critical for me.
If the recommendation service
were to actually start
performing like this, I would
be close to-- and maybe even
would--
exceed my SLO and run
out of error budget.
So what am I going to do?
Well, first I would tell
the recommendations team,
you should be setting
your own SLOs.
I need you to be returning
faster than one second.
So I want you to have a
stricter SLO than that
so you catch your own errors.
But second, it tells me
that I should make sure
that the front end is
resilient and, in fact,
maybe can time out if the
recommendation service takes
too long.
Anthos Service Mesh can
help with that as well.
Now I'm going to talk about
a different sort of chaos
we can inject and
that is failures.
As we said before,
the service mesh
is telling me exactly how
my system is related--
how many services
comprise it and how
they relate to each other.
Here, you can see
my front end talks
to a service called
the cart service.
Now the cart service
is an important service
in my application.
People can't see what they're
buying if they can't put things
in the cart.
However, if that should
fail at some point,
I still want the
system to be resilient.
So I'm going to
use Anthos Service
Mesh to inject some chaos.
I've got a file here
called cart error.
Again, it's using the
open source Istio APIs.
And it's saying,
hey, in the cart
service I want you 100% of
the time to throw a 500.
I'm not going to have to
redeploy the application,
and I'm not going to have
to recode the application.
I'm just going to tell
the service mesh to start
returning these errors.
I've already made this change,
and I have made a commitment.
And I can see all I
need to do is push this,
and it will-- or
commit this, push it,
and it will take effect.
So we're got to inject
some chaos here.
And then I'm going to push this.
Now, my system of record, which
is the source code repository,
has the new policy.
Anthos Config Management
is taking that policy
and pushing it into
each of my clusters.
And as soon as they do, I can
see the effects of that policy.
So my application is
still here and running.
And wow, is that a
catastrophic failure.
Now again, the shopping
cart service is important,
but this is not acceptable.
This is telling me that I
need to be more resilient.
So now I'm going to have to go
to the front-end application
team and make sure that they
are resilient to a failure
from the shopping
cart application.
Now I do want to say, you
saw that injecting chaos
put some serious breakage
in our application.
I don't recommend you do
this in your production
in clusters, at least at first.
Try this in your dev clusters.
Now I'd like to turn
it over to Tony,
who is going to talk about
Cloud Run for Anthos.
TONY PUJALS: Thanks, Dan.
So Dan, just did
a really great job
of explaining the benefits
of microservice architecture
and what Anthos does to help
you manage these applications
that you've deployed.
But what can we do to improve
that experience for developers?
So the metaphor here is I want
to be productive in my space.
I want enjoy my space.
But I don't want have to do all
the work to create the space
and maintain it.
So how can Cloud Run for
Anthos help us with that?
What we see here is that
Cloud Run for Anthos
is right here at the
top of this stack,
meaning that it is focused
on the developer experience.
And what can we do to improve
that developer experience?
We're going to get to that.
Why would you choose
Cloud Run for Anthos?
In a nutshell, the
idea is that you're
going to get all the
benefits of containerized
of your microservice
applications
but without the overhead
of managing infrastructure
and dealing with some
of the complexity
that Kubernetes introduces
when you work at the Kubernetes
level for your applications.
So looking here, what
we see is a spectrum
where you can
deploy applications
directly on-prem as
vm.prem or in the cloud.
And on the far right, we
have a fully managed service
experience.
But for whatever reason
that your org has chosen
Anthos is likely
because you need
to run certain applications that
don't fit the service model.
You've got infrastructure
that you do have to manage.
But for those applications
that could benefit
from the serviceless
approach, you
can leverage Cloud
Run for Anthos
without having to worry
about the infrastructure
for those applications
that you deploy.
Cloud Run for Anthos
leverages is Knative, which
is built on top of Kubernetes.
And therefore, your
operators and everybody
in your environment
familiar with Kubernetes
already gets to leverage that.
But from the
developer experience,
you're going to be able to
deploy your applications using
a much more simplified model.
And I'm going to demonstrate
exactly what that means
because I'm going to take
the same app that Dan was
demonstrating, and I'm
going to migrate it
to Cloud Run for Anthos.
All right, let's dive in.
This is the repo for
the microservices demo
app that's launched as part of
the Anthos sample deployment
that Dan used.
It's a fairly
high-fidelity example
of a sophisticated
microservices application built
for a fictional enterprise.
It's published as an e-commerce
website called Online Boutique.
And architecturally, it's
composed of 10 microservices
that communicate over GRPC.
And it's got a data store that
we've simulated with Redis.
And also we've added
a load generator
so that we can simulate a
bunch of users sending traffic
to the public front end.
It's typically deployed
as a Kubernetes plus Istio
application, as Dan
previously demonstrated.
So what I'm going
to show you is how
with just some
configuration changes,
you can take advantage of a
simplified serviceless model
and seamlessly integrate this
with existing workloads running
on your Kubernetes clusters.
And that's the main point I'm
going to be driving here today.
So in other words,
this demo isn't
going to be about all the
benefits of serverless per se.
There's already a ton
of content about that.
More importantly, I want to show
you how Cloud Run for Anthos
makes it easy for your
ops team to provide you
with the benefits of serviceless
coexisting seamlessly
in your Kubernetes environments.
This will leverage your
operator's expertise,
along with the benefits
of using Anthos,
our application
modernization platform.
And so with Cloud
Run for Anthos,
you're going to get to exploit
the best developer deployment
model that makes the most
sense for each service
that you build and deploy.
And just to take a look at--
here are the Kubernetes
manifests and the Istio
manifests.
And so what we're
going to do is--
what you'll want to do
is fork my repo here,
Cloud Run for Anthos Labs and
go to this sample right here.
And here all the
instructions are
provided, so everything
that I'm going to show you
can be found in this
repo, including a script
that you're going to need--
well, that you can use for
creating a Kubernetes cluster
with GKE.
And if you want to create a
cluster using the web console,
just remember to make sure that
you check the box Enable Cloud
Run for Anthos for the cluster.
This line here
basically is the part
that ensures that our cluster
is going to have the full Cloud
Run for Anthos support enabled.
Now I have already done
this to save some time,
so let's go to our Kubernetes
Engine dashboard and confirm.
I've got cluster 1 here.
This is just a Kubernetes
cluster running on GKE.
And this is what was
installed with the cluster--
with the Cloud Run
support enabled.
The only services
running on it right now--
let me sort here by namespace.
So within the GKE
connect namespace,
what we're going to see is
support for Cloud Run error
reporting and logging to
Stackdriver, control plane
component for configuring
our cluster local gateway
for all the traffic and
microservice and microservice
internal traffic, as well as our
public ingress to the cluster.
And these last four
services are all
required to provide that
serviceless foundation
on top of Kubernetes that makes
Cloud Run for Anthos work.
So now that we've
got a cluster, we're
going to want to
deploy our application.
Let's take a look at the
configuration changes
that we need to make this work
with Cloud Run for Anthos.
Quick refresher, here's the
architecture of our application
once again.
I want to point out that
the load generator is
a long-running service that
is intended to send traffic
as long as that
service is running
and until it's terminated.
So as a long-running
service, this
is not a good candidate for
running as a serviceless app.
And therefore,
this is going to be
deployed as a standard
Kubernetes service.
So the same thing is true
for Redis, which is also not
a good candidate for serviceless
because it requires an attached
volume.
And this isn't
consistent with the goals
of running as a Knative service
under the hood for auto scaling
purposes.
It's not a good fit for
the serviceless model.
So this is a
long-running service,
and this is a
state-full service.
These are both going to be
deployed as normal Kubernetes
deployments.
The rest of these will be
deployed as serviceless apps.
So what we're going to
look at is the delta
between the original Kubernetes
manifest in this repo
and the manifest
that I have added
for you in this repo under
the Knative directory.
And what I'm going
to do, actually,
is I'm going to switch
over to my editor
because I want to give you
a little bit of an overview
about what changes
before I actually
drill into the details.
So for one thing, Knative offers
a simplified configuration
abstraction.
There's a single
service here compared
to the need for two different
configurations-- a service
and a deployment--
under Kubernetes.
And because of
that, you don't need
all of these
selectors and labels
to correlate the
two configurations.
You also don't need
to predetermined
the number of
replicas you're going
to need in anticipation of load
and availability requirements.
You can take
advantage of the fact
that Knative provides auto
scaling out of the box,
you can still configure
minimum and maximum limits
if you want to, but
again, you don't
have to anticipate that load.
And if you only have a single
container in your service,
you don't even need to
give the container a name.
Minor simplifications
but when you
look at all of these in
aggregate, what you'll find
is that Knative offers a very
nice simplified configuration
abstraction for your
service resources.
So now let's dive into
the actual configuration
in more detail.
Here, under the
Knative V1 directory,
let's open up this
services YAML file.
And actually, the first one
that I want to start with,
I'll start with the
front end since that's
the logical entry point
for the application anyway.
What we see here--
so the front-end services
is exposed to the internet.
It serves the web
user interface,
and it communicates with
various back-end services.
What you'll see here,
obviously, the first two lines
declaring that this is
a service resource using
the Knative serving API.
We've provided a
name and metadata.
That name needs to be
unique within the namespace.
There's no namespace
that we specified here,
so the default is default.
There's only one
container provided here.
We only need one container
for this service.
So there is no name for it.
The front-end service
expects environment variables
with DNS name colon
port values to be
set for each of the
back-end services
that it will send requests to.
So note also that
all of these services
are in the default namespace
as well as indicated
by their DNS names.
The Kubernetes compute
resource requirements
for the container are specified
here and at least 10% of a VCU
limited to 20% and at least
64 megabytes to start with
and a limit of double that.
Since the front-end service
listens on the port identified
at runtime with the port
environment variable that
is automatically set
by Knative, there's
no need to specify a
container port value here
as some of the
other services will
that we'll see in a moment.
The Default for
the port is 8080,
but it's a good practice
for a Knative service
to get the value of that
port environment variable
anyway, which this app does.
So now that we've covered
that, let's move on.
Let's go to the Add Service.
So the front end fetches
short text advertisements
to display from Add
Service by sending
lists of important keywords
from the current page describing
context.
And there's important things
to note here, just two things.
In addition to
the name, there is
metadata that is used to
configure the services
visibility as cluster local.
And this means that
there's no public access
to the add service.
It's a private cluster
local-only service
that is accessible from
within the cluster.
The container port
is set to 8080.
And although that's
actually the default,
because we need
to provide this--
and I'll explain
this in a moment--
we've got to provide
the full configuration.
So we do have to
specify container port.
The reason why
we're providing name
is this is a specific name
that indicates that we're going
to be communicating with GRPC.
Or technically, this
is HTTP/2 over TCP.
That's what the H2C stands for.
If this isn't provided, then
the default under Knative
would be HTTP/1.
Let's see.
Moving on, cart service.
OK, so this provides the
shopping cart functionality
for the app.
The configuration should start
looking pretty familiar by now.
There's only a couple of
things we need to note here.
The app does take a port
option, this minus p,
and we get the value
from the port environment
variable that's set by Knative.
It's listening on
8080, and, again,
this is a GRPC service,
HTTP/2 over TCP.
A couple of other environment
variables getting set here.
And basically, that's it.
And let's see, checkout service.
Checkout service is
used to purchase items
that the customer has
added to their cart.
And like the front end and the
cart service that we just saw,
the checkout service uses
environment variables
to get the addresses to
use for its back ends
that it communicates with.
And that's it here.
Currency service is used to
convert currencies and display
price.
And here, we can see
that it actually listens
on a specific port, 7000.
So this would need to
be specified anyway,
even if we weren't using
GRPC, which we are.
Email service sends ordering
and payment confirmation
after purchase.
And it's already been mentioned,
but the only reason, again,
for this specific port,
even though it's a default,
is because, again,
this is a GRPC.
All of these services
are going to be
GRPC except for the front end.
We covered the front end.
Payment service is used to
make purchases at checkout.
And there's nothing really
new to explain about this.
Product catalog service is
used to convert currencies
when displaying price.
And again, this
should look familiar.
Nothing new to explain here.
Recommendation service is
used to make similar product
recommendations while
browsing and nothing new
to explain here.
And the shipping service, which
is used to purchase products--
which is used to ship
your purchase products,
and there's nothing
new to explain there.
So this is all we had to
do to take our Kubernetes
manifest-- it was basically
about what we stripped out.
We did have to add some things.
We had to add labels that
constrained our visibility
and had to provide these hints
as to the type of traffic
that we want.
And that's it.
So now let's just take a
look at deploying the app.
I'll go ahead and
start up a couple
of watches for our
Kubernetes deployment
and also around the
case service resources.
That just gives us
another perspective
on deploying these services.
I'll want to deploy
our back end for Redis.
Remember, this was a state-full
service with a volume attached,
so this is just a normal
Kubernetes deployment.
And then I'm going to
deploy the app itself.
And for now, I'm going to deploy
the second version of the app.
Go to the repo,
check out the lab
to see what it means to
have scaling to 0 configured
and what it means for auto
scaling up in the V3 version.
But this will just be
the V2 version, where
I've set minimum scale to 1.
So
The services never
actually scale to 0.
Because for these
services for the website,
we're going to expect a
responsive user interface.
So this is a nice
thing to be able to do.
But scaling to 0 is
normally the default.
That's also great
for services that
don't need to run all the time
and consume compute resources
for what you're getting billed.
Now that the app is
running, I can curl it.
So let's see, to
do that, I'm going
to need to know the gateway IP.
Send the GKE system
namespace or Istio ingress.
And there's the IP.
I'll also need to know the
DNS name for the route--
for the front end.
And what we'll see here
is actually, by default,
the domain would've
been example.com.
I provided a custom mapping,
just another configuration
that you apply.
I took this basic template,
and I configured for a domain
that I control, tonypujals.com.
So that's what we're
seeing right there.
If I curl it, this
request is going
to go to the ingress
gateway, and it
needs to know to which
service to send it.
And so with curl,
I'm going to do that
by providing a host header.
So our front-end service
in the default namespace,
it would, by default,
be example.com.
But in this case, since I
provided a custom domain
mapping, it's tonypujals.com.
And here is the IP that
we're going to send that to.
And there you go.
We can see that
a page responded.
We can also do this
in the browser.
Now if I send it
to the IP address,
obviously, I can't
set it to example.com.
Since that's not my domain, I
can't configure records for it.
If I set it to the
IP address, I need
to do something
similar like we just
did here when we curled it.
I need to supply
that host header.
So you can use a mod
header Chrome extension,
specify your host header,
apply some filter pattern
so it doesn't apply to every
other website that you go to.
And there you go.
This is great for
local testing until you
go through the trouble
of actually configuring
that custom domain,
but you can test.
Since I did configure
for my domain,
I can also take advantage
of the automatic certificate
for HTTPS support.
And there you go, I'm at the
top level of tonypujals.com.
Here's the application.
You've never seen it before.
It's a simple online
shopping experience.
For each one of these
items, I can drill in.
I can see that
the recommendation
service is providing other
products that are similar.
I can see ads.
If I refresh this page,
some stuff will update.
Add stuff to the cart, place
your order, off you go.
Last thing I want
to you real quick
is I want to go over
to the Cloud Run
dashboard in our console.
There's all the
services running.
For each one of
these services, you
can get access to its
performance, the resources it's
consuming, take a
look at logs, even go
over directly to the Stackdriver
page under Ops Logging Console
and get access to a
ton of information
about how things are doing as
well as take a look, again,
at the logs but with control
over how you want to filter,
what you want to know.
Let's see my
container logs, which
are in the default namespace
for my main containers.
And maybe I want to
watch some streaming.
OK, so let's go back
here to the repo.
This is where you want to go.
There's a lab.
These are all the steps to be
able to get through this lab,
including checking out
all the auto scaling
stuff that I didn't demonstrate,
scaling to 0 and scaling up.
And then finally, cleaning
up when you're all done.
I hope what I did
demonstrate though is
that with Cloud Run for
Anthos, you can definitely
take advantage of
your Kubernetes,
your existing
companies clusters,
and seamlessly coexist with
your Kubernetes workloads.
And that, to me, is the
biggest value proposition
of Cloud Run for Anthos,
that and the fact
that your developers
get to exploit
the serverless programming
model that will
accelerate their development.
So thanks a lot, and
back to you, Dan.
DAN CIRULI: Thanks, Tony.
That was amazing.
I bet after watching
two of these deep dives,
you're ready to try
Anthos for yourself.
Great news.
We're ready for you to try that.
Just go to goo.gle/tryanthos.
That's goo.gle/tryanthos And
we've got a fully-hosted,
hands-on trial that'll spin
up a cluster where you can
experiment with all of
these features yourselves.
Thanks very much for your time.